thank you
good evening and welcome to this
performance governance and audit
committee meeting on 17th of November
2022 my name is councilor Jane Fleming
and I'm chairing this committee this
evening members we are streaming this
meeting live as well as recording and by
being present in the meeting you are
giving your consent to being recorded
during each item please raise your hand
to indicate that you wish to speak I
will then invite you at the appropriate
time
please note that the YouTube live stream
sound recording is dependent on correct
use of the microphones
therefore can I ask that when invited to
speak you remember to turn on your
microphone and turn it off when finished
please reference a page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers and keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible
may I have apologies for absence please
Berner
thank you chairman we proceed topologies
for absence from councilor stack thank
you Berner
turning to the minutes it is recommended
that the minutes of the meeting held on
the 29th of September 2022 found on
pages 5 to 12 are approved as a true and
accurate record I so moved do I have a
seconder for that motion
thank you
seconded if any member wishes to raise
any matter of accuracy they need to
indicate that they wish to speak
anyone
good thank you can we agree by sent or
take a vote
so burn a counselor still seconded that
did you see that
okay good are we all agreed members yes
okay
okay good Declarations of interest to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests other
registerable interests and non-regisible
interests relating to items of business
on the agenda having regard to paragraph
9 and appendix B of the code of conduct
for members members are reminded that
they are also required to disclose any
such interest as soon as they become
aware should the need arise through the
meeting members does anyone have a
declaration
foreign
thank you moving on to public
participation I can advise that we have
not received any submissions from
members of the public
so turning to agenda item six the
internal audit report
found on pages 13 to 14 together with
the associated reports from BDO LLP the
council's internal Auditors at 6A to 60
on the agenda Pages 15 to 68 in total Mr
Rubens welcome please rep present your
reports thank you
foreign
good evening everyone
um so we have four reports to present
tonight I'm going to briefly introduce
each report and then pause in case
members have any questions so the first
one item a is our progress report
um and you'll see from the papers we
have two reports we finalized which are
present in due course
um uh commercialization and flood
management
um we also have two outing draft
safeguarding and contract management so
just waiting for final management
responses on those two and they they
will be ready for next time
um we've also made a slight change to
the plan
with climate change and sustainability
is going to be deferred to next year uh
next year's plan because
um to give time for the strategy to be
developed and embedded and instead we're
going to bring forward the audit of
cyber security which we had in next
year's plan uh I think that would be
quite useful given the focus on that
area at the moment so so
um though that's all I wanted to say on
the progress report item a happy to take
any questions on that
so I can't actually find Mr rubin's
report buried in all of this where is
there a separate report sorry page
number or something I think handsome
fluka um Mr Rubens is referring to 6A at
the moment just for sort of General
synopsis before moving on to the other
uh reports so uh that's page 17 of your
pack or I believe
should we tell you
summary of work
members does anyone have anything to ask
Mr Rubens
on 6a
Council fluke are you happy with that
yeah I mean as far as I've found sort of
page 17 but um
I'll go with Mr Wilkins thank you Mr
ribbons
okay so item 6B is our follow-up of
previous recommendations
um and we've been able to mark seven uh
recommendations uh as complete that
we've followed up there are two overdue
they both relate to the um management of
property audit that we did
um so they're the reason given is that
there's been a delay in uh implementing
uh and introducing the new property
management system and that's required in
order to gather all the data that we
were saying is needed
um I mean there clearly is some risk
while that is being done we we if you
remember the audit report was that the
council didn't have a very clear picture
on all of its assets and all the repairs
and maintenance associated with that so
um until that system is introduced I'm
not sure if there's any mitigating
controls but clearly
um that remains at a risk as far as
we're concerned
thank you members any questions on
report 6B
thank you
Mr Rubens okay so item 6C is our audit
report on commercialization
um that's given uh I think it's a
positive report we've given substantial
Assurance on the design of the controls
and moderate Assurance on the
effectiveness of the controls
um the council has a lot of good
practice there has a very clear
commercial strategy the governance
arrangements are generally very good and
you know good progress reporting and
focus around commercial Arrangements the
key issue we found was some
inconsistency in the way that the
project processes were being used so and
not in every case we couldn't we
couldn't always find that there was a a
separate business case or benchmarking
being done for example to ensure that
value for money was being achieved it
should be you'll note from the manage
the officer's responses that we were
looking at some older schemes and there
have been some improvements introduced
since which should mean that those areas
have been rectified and we shouldn't
find that going forwards but clearly
there was there were some
recommendations resulting which had been
accepted and should be implemented in
due course
thank you Mr Rubens members any
questions on agenda item 6C councilor
fluka
thank you chairman um so you I just
wanted to ask Mr rubin's Question
um about risk management and
commercialization at a recent uh meeting
of this Council I asked a question
around Pacific risk registers and I was
surprised to hear that there wasn't one
for the largest project that were
actually undertaking although with
fairness although that project some way
forward now I had been promised that but
I'm surprised that you didn't pick up on
that because risking commercialization
in any Council tends to be very very
high and I certainly would expect to see
a specific risk register for that area
of commercialization
thank you councilor Mr Rubens
um well I mean we we do actually comment
on that on page 44 when we looked at one
project where we said that the the
um specific risks weren't weren't always
considered and there were some
weaknesses in the risk management around
that particular project that we looked
at so that was one of the areas where
um we felt there needed to be um you
know more focused around making sure
that risks are being done again it's
part of the action plan
um the the implementation date is
February uh of next year so I would hope
and expect that that to be in kept to be
implemented by then but I certainly take
your point and as I said we did find
that an issue on one of the projects we
looked at
yes yeah okay I noticed that you you you
sort of identified that but I would have
thought you would have mentioned the
correct mitigation which would have been
a Pacific Rich risk register uh and and
I'm slightly more concerned now because
you know February's three months away
and this is quite a big project and it
seems to be gathering speed but you know
I'm I'm sure that Mr butcher will
um send out the risk register tomorrow
morning and they'll put us all in our
comfort zone
thank you councilor fluka uh no I think
you raise uh an important Point
um you know commercialization although
it's
um obviously provides opportunities has
risks we only have to look to other
authorities that have got themselves in
some difficulty in Essex as a sort of
timely reminder that scrutiny uh of
commercialization is vitally important
um
if I can just make a comment from the
chair
I feel that a wider attendance on the
working group would be beneficial
um I don't know how many members sit on
it at the moment six maybe I personally
think that it should be widened out
to ensure that there are more members
present thank you anybody else at this
stage
counselor fluka well chairman really
just to come back on what you said
um you know I'm finding it I'm finding
it
more and more hard that we had these
working groups and they seem to be you
know the attendance of members at them
is is quite low
um which is you know quite unusual to
where we've been in you know people used
to fight to get onto these working
groups and now they seem to get on them
and of course that leaves the offices in
a very difficult position because if
they're expecting the input from six and
they only have the input from two uh and
then things start to progress
um you know that's not really fair to
anybody so uh maybe that's something you
should take up with your uh your um
leader thank you thank you councilor
fluka
[Music]
um
I I do think it's a valid point and I
think if you have six um because we
can't sub onto working groups perhaps we
should have you know maybe 10 members
and then that uh would cover
um you know people can't make it or if
they have diary clashes I think Charlie
if you let me come back I mean you know
we do tend to have this sort of uh
um sort of acceptance that I think
depending on what the working group is
any members can attend
um so there is always that sort of
safety net but it's just that you know
some of these working groups they are
poorly had attended
thank you anybody else Council Channel
thank you for letting me speak Madam Jim
actually um the leader of the opposition
and I did when we spoke about this and
councilor stilts is here so she might
recall I hope and in fact council Mrs
Thompson is that is one of the working
groups actually I believe we did
increase the numbers on because actually
we considered the numbers that were
running originally weren't
um sort of perhaps the numbers so I
think we upped it up by two and also
regarding substitutes as you recall I
hope um the recent conversation we had
where I did perhaps ask that this uh
with the chairman I don't know if that
conversation has been heard yet about
bringing forward that I think there
should be substitutions for working
groups but it's not in our constitution
they've run without that that would be
very very helpful and indeed when we've
had her aware that someone couldn't
attend we've spoken to the chairman of a
working Group corporate projects working
group and in fact another member fell in
I think it was the councilor Durham who
who couldn't attend so councilor Mrs
Thompson fell in but I'm hoping
um or I can do it by emotion whichever
might be easier but I was hoping that
conversation might have been had with
the chairman of this committee but I can
do that as well but I did it through use
the vice chairman perhaps uh giving you
that sort of bit of um how can I put it
approach to you know taking it forward
thank you thank you Council Lieutenant I
did indeed raise it with councilor stamp
and misuse uh just the other day so I'm
hoping we can get something sorted out
on that good any other members
want to comment on agenda item 6C the
report before we move on
no
thank you
so the final report item 6D is our
report on flood management
um this is provided moderate Assurance
on the design and the effectiveness of
the controls
um we have seen some improvements since
we audited this last so there has been
some effort being put in into improving
Arrangements uh governance uh we think
is is better there seems to be more
um activity from the council and
officers around flood management there's
been also the development of a strategic
flood uh protection action plan which
was something we recommended last time
so that's good to see that in place
um there were there are some issues that
we've raised in the report
um one is around lack of Engagement from
angling water
um obviously the council has perhaps
limited ability to
um to deal with that but it is an issue
that needs to be looked at
um and there were three recommendations
still outstanding from our last audit
some relate to training but also the
need for a sustainable drainage system
strategy which was a recommendation from
last time so still some work to do but
we are seeing some improvements and
again happy to take any comments or
questions
thank you Mr Rubens members
any comments
nothing anyone all very quiet this
evening
nope
thank you Mr rooms if we can move on to
the next report
yeah I think that's that's it yeah good
okay
so if we if nobody has any questions I
will move on to the recommendations
the recommendations are found on page 13
of the report I will read them out that
the committee considers comments and
approves the following Little One
internal audit progress report July 2022
at 6 a
to follow up recommendations report July
2022 6B
little three commercialization reports
May 2022 6C and little four flood
management report
2021
20226d do I have a seconder councilor
stilts is seconding
okay do we uh do we can we agree that by
Ascent members
yep everybody happy
good okay any other items of business
that the chairman decides are Urgent I
do have one
um from counselor stilts thank you
councilor stills
thank you madam chair this is actually a
question for uh Mr Leslie
um why is there no external Auditor's
report and when was the last time they
reported and come Mr Leslie tell the
committee if the last external external
audit has been signed off and if not why
also will there be will there be
charging more than agreed with the last
chair of this committee and how much
more will all this cost the council
thank you cancer silts Mr Leslie thank
you I've agreed with the chair that a
update report will be going to the next
PGA committee uh around the audit side
of it like most local authorities
um audits have experienced significant
delays and that's been reported on uh
nationally as well around that you can
see in the statistics that there's a lot
fewer councils having audits completed
within the time frame and indeed still
currently and that's largely the case
across Essex at the moment Auditors are
working to catch up with a lot of the
delays all that they're put in in
additional resources and time frames
around that and we're seeing a lot more
progress over the over the past month uh
indeed with our audit and also with the
audits nationally as well around that
side of it so we'll be able to give an
update report to the committee at the
next meeting on that in terms of the
charges um
that side of it won't be agreed until
the audit has finished
fees will be going to the psaa the
um body that determines and agrees the
fees independently between the Auditors
and the councils so they will have
ultimate sign off around that and we
have a much clearer picture within the
next couple of months around that as
well so the Auditors are finishing the
accounts for the
um
uh two years uh passed
um and we still will be then picking up
the
um 21 22 set of accounts um as well the
council has published its accounts the
council published its accounts on time
so it have done
um what uh what it can do in terms of
meeting its obligations so the accounts
are online and published in their draft
versions in the time frame for the
Publications have been met
thank you Mr Leslie uh councilor stilts
would you like to come back
no thank you you're done good cancer
fluka Sue
so for the period 2021 based on what you
know are there likely to be any material
changes
um and I mean
I don't quite understand why they're
late
returning the audit because you know the
external Auditors haven't been under the
pressures that local government have
been under
um is there any specific reason why
they're they're late and material
changes thank you
yeah so in terms of the pressures around
the audit Market which has been reported
on has been experienced nationally it's
due in part to resourcing issues within
that sector it's also due to a number of
changes in the audit regulations and
requirements as well for example value
for money um you also be a
Redmond review as well and government
reviews do sort of cover the pressures
around that and they are published
reports from government out there
outlining some of the issues and some of
the proposed resolutions around that
side as well so that's added to the
National picture around resourcing in
terms of material changes we give an
update to the committee at the next
meeting I think we've already reported
on one of the aspects around
classification which required Kobe
grants to be removed from one from the
incoming expenditure account line and
just reclassified within the balance
sheet in terms of the impact on the
bottom line then no there is no impact
it's major a reclassification of where
it's shown within the statement of
accounts and currently with the audit
nearing completion we're not expecting
any significant impact on the bottom
line to a material extent although there
will be some as I've said
reclassifications within that which do
not result in a impact on the bottom
line but that will be coming forward and
give an update on that
thank you Mr Leslie councilor Fleek are
you satisfied with that oh absolutely
I'm grateful for the update thank you
thank you
uh okay members if that is all
um I will
members and officers thank you for your
contributions this evening I now draw
the meeting to a close at uh 7 52 I make
it thank you
thank you